we got to talk about this other psychic  too which is the nude portraits of you  like did you know about the like did you  know about this  well they they called me in and said the  art department would like to meet with  you  and um i said great and i think i went  in maybe an hour two before call time  you know i had on jeans and a a a  flannel shirt when they did that so  there was no they were just they they  were guessing i said just make it  flattering and and i just turned kind of  halfway sideways like that so um and  they drew me and they put it up and i  love that they did my husband in a  wheelchair i've never seen a nude  picture of a man in a wheelchair before  so kudos to the art department did you  ask for your own portrait i would have  said can i please have it when it's done  guys christmas is coming early for you  today okay  oh my god  no way  oh  my  for their  friends she has the portrait of her her  own nude portrait behind her